shelling rang out across eastern ukraine
as russian-backed forces allegedly
opened fire striking targets including a
kindergarten
the children had been whisked away just
moments before
the u.s now believes there's little
doubt a full-scale russian attack is
coming nearly half of russia's amassed
forces are within 50 kilometers of
ukraine's border my sense this will
happen in the next several days yet u.s
president joe biden said he had no plans
to call russia's vladimir putin and in a
worrying sign russia expelled the deputy
u.s ambassador from moscow after
delivering written demands that the u.s
claw back nato or face so-called
military technical measures we don't
know what will happen but what we do
know
is that russia has amassed the biggest
force we have seen in europe for decades
russia's claim to have moved troops away
from ukraine is false according to nato
instead they say an extra 7 000 troops
were added to the 150 000 already
perched and ready to strike
i am here today
not to start a war
but to prevent one at the u.n security
council the u.s secretary of state led
the international rallying cry against
war
outlining how putin might carry out an
invasion by first creating a false
pretext we don't know exactly the form
it will take
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of a mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons
russia has already claimed mass graves
exist in disputed pro-russian regions of
ukraine and putin is said to be
preparing a rare address to the russian
parliament the u.s says it believes any
russian action would target specific
groups and key sites within ukraine
including the capital kiev
all the while ukraine soldiers on
president vladimir zelinsky toured the
front lines for a second straight day
walking a fine line staring down the
russian threat while trying not to get
dragged into a bloody conflict
jackson cross go global news washington